we all want to be happy but the majority
of us have no idea what to do see the
Japanese have a concept called ikigai
which roughly translates into a reason
for being you need to have a purpose for
being here but this is easier said than
done because there are four components
that you need to check off in order to
achieve ikigai the fourth and final
component is that it needs to be
something that you're good at now this
doesn't mean that you need to be born
with Talent this actually means that
you're able to put in the time and
effort in order to get better at this
skill let's say for example you want to
become a motivational speaker when you
first get started you're terrible you
have stage fright you stutter a lot you
forget what you're supposed to say but
over time as you practice more and more
you start to overcome these obstacles
that's what it means to be good at
something not to be good from the get-go
but to be able to overcome obstacles and
improve at this skill this overcoming of
obstacles creates a very fulfilling
feeling inside of you which is why it's
such a crucial component of ikigai
follow us for more helpful tips